keep praying for us keep praying for our
family that we get through this and that
god leads us in the right direction of
what we need to do next
the i-team sharing that man's story two
years ago his mother killed in a
murder-suicide by a man she met online
just weeks prior now the i-team shows us
how criminals are using these dating
apps to isolate and target their victims
these romantic meetups often end in
violence we have the i-team's david
charns joining us in studio with how
investigators say you can be aware david
yeah that's right so important to say a
lot of dates go as normal and go off
fine but these are apps that you and
your family may have used before we're
talking pretty popular ones like plenty
of fish and tinder easy ways to find a
potential date right but now police say
criminals are actually using these apps
not to find love
you never know who's on the other end of
that computer screen on the other side
of the screen a sweetheart a swipe away
an app that many people use for normal
dating
type scenarios
but metro lieutenant william matchkow
says that date didn't go as planned here
at caesar's palace investigators say a
man met 25 year old april lean sablin on
plenty of fish the popular dating app
she invited him upstairs and about a
minute later 35 year old zanier kalisar
was also there all of a sudden he was
isolated and trapped
in a very dangerous situation police say
khalasar punched the victim the pair
demanding hundreds of dollars what he
wouldn't give in police say the duo then
turned to facebook making their victim
undress and live streaming the video the
incident ending when police say the two
took their victim to an atm and he ran
for help i think that a lot of people in
the public sometimes are naive as to
what they're getting themselves into
matchko says criminals are turning to
popular dating apps to lure unsuspecting
lovers people with good intentions
falling right into their trap you may go
out there and meet your dream partner
you may meet your future husband or wife
and you could live happily ever after
you could put yourself in a situation
like this gentleman where you become a
victim of a serious violent crime and
many of those crimes are going
unreported the best advice meet in
public and don't isolate yourself you
never know who's really on the other
side the worst thing that can happen is
the point where it becomes too late
now we did reach out to plenty of fish
for this story we did not hear back but
the company and many other popular
dating apps like tinder do offer tips to
protect yourself including the obvious
one just don't isolate yourself with a
stranger the company is also offering a
service to connect you with police in an
emergency but thing is you've got to
have your phone near you i'm david
charns 8 news now